his question for you how long does CEUs
plastic like this take to degrade when
it ends up in the sea 70 years 80 years
takes 1991 yes maybe I was sixty four
hundred and fifty years excited to find
out what they wouldn't be like finding a
Roman coin anything Agee why do we need
plastic rod to the easy to manufacture
change into different things are very
humble these are completely different
shapes and one I use somewhere else that
doesn't take an eternity to degrade you
donate because it's probably cheaper and
people don't like is it because we just
cannot be bothered yes all these things
that daddy was talking about my daddy
and I were little they're all in glass
bottles fizzy drinks came in bottles and
you pay deposit back and they gave you
some money I don't know even though
people know it's a help I care for the
environment they're not gonna change
everything because AIDS effort be it's
money and yeah if you've got a way to
work people are just gonna change
everything
yeah hands up if you used straw in the
last month
why'd you need a straw you don't need to
ask for a straw you don't need to accept
plastic straws you can just drink
straight from the cup there's lifestyle
choices like not choosing table
[Music]
like that Beach is gonna be cold today -
really got scarves
I just watch I do think that to be this
much like there's a pin literally just
over there and it was located here you
spent 20 minutes on the beach what have
we found this is God's got a straw some
[ __ ] tops we were there for about
15-20 minutes and found all these bottle
tops how long does it take in the sea
that is plastic to decompose we did we
leave it all here we're gonna do with it
recycling